hey there guys Happy New Year and happy
Christmas hope you had a great one if
there's one thing everybody loves it's a
cliche and so I give you YouTuber
talking about his goals and Ambitions at
the start of the new year so in this
video I'm going to be breaking down my
training and my business goals gonna
talk about my training program how it
went last year what I'm going to be
doing differently next year if you're
interested in how I actually train in
the nuts and bolts of it then you'll
find that information here I'm not
really going to talk about my personal
goals outside of business and training
because I mean that's probably pretty
boring to you guys we're having to move
into a bigger house but I mean yeah so
we're going to focus on training goals
and what you can expect from the channel
going forwards I'm going to recap on
what I did well last year and what did
badly and hopefully some of the
strategies I'm going to be using to
improve things which I also hope might
be applicable to you guys and the goals
that you're going to be following going
into next year speaking of fantastic
goals for 2023 they're a few better than
learning a new language and what would
you know that brings me perfectly to
today's sponsor Babble as you guys know
I've been learning a little bit of
Polish because I have a Polish
background and for me learning terms
like Tak for yes and Jin queer for thank
you it's just really nostalgic and nice
to hear that language again
it's also fantastic for your brain
learning a language as you guys know and
babble is just a fantastic tool for
doing it not only because it's
convenient and easy to use wherever you
are if you just want to fit in a few
minutes of training but also because of
the way it uses intuitive and
conversation based lessons taught by
real language teachers that makes a real
difference up to here if any of you guys
are interested in learning a language
and which one and why let me know in the
comments down below and if you are then
I highly recommend using Babble as a
great way to get started and better yet
if you click the link in the description
down below you'll also get 60 off of
your subscription which is a really
decent deal so check it out and happy
language learning now on with the show
so looking back on 2022 it was on the
whole a good year although it had its
ups and downs it was my first full year
as a parent of two and that definitely
came with its challenges and that did
you know encroach onto my training and
my business for sure I had a new book
published which you can find in the
description down below adaptive training
so that was a a big win for the channel
the site continued to grow I increased
the production value we got a drone and
stuff like that did more work with Grant
and also some with Liam which was great
hopefully you guys have noticed the
production value generally improve at
the start of the year the site in the
channel had a big Surge and nearly every
video I did went really really well it
seemed like I could do no wrong in the
eyes of the YouTube algorithm at the
moment that's not quite the case I've
had quite a few flops and Duds which is
disheartening but that is one of the
things I'm going to be looking at going
forwards in terms of my training that
also had its ups and downs I definitely
made some progress in some key areas in
particular my Mobility improved in
certain regards but at the same time I I
also may be overreached and pushed
myself a little bit too far as you guys
know a few months back I made a video
talking about burnout and how I was a
little bit you know overworked and I'd
hurt my back quite badly and my son
wasn't sleeping at the time so my wife
and I were getting very little sleep on
a nightly basis which really was
starting to take a toll I didn't feel
particularly physically impressive and
to be honest that can cause a bit of
imposter syndrome the problem was trying
to look after the kids and not have any
sleep and at the same time film all
these videos and at the same time work
out and in particular the filming can be
brutal because I'll be filming for a
whole day often Outdoors doing stuff
that I wouldn't normally do as part of
my training and then I have to recover
from that and how can I train around
that so that was definitely really a
challenge last year especially when I
then hurt my back and especially with
the lack of sleep and I took on much
more work for sponsors which has all
been fantastic because you know I'm very
lucky to have all these great sponsors
but at the same time that caused a lot
of stress meant a lot more deadlines
meant that I had to wait for them to
respond which hurt my you know timing of
uploads all these things things and yeah
just got a little bit much fortunately I
can now report I'm feeling much better
at the moment and partly that's because
of one of my new rules for 2023 not so
much a goal just a rule of something I'm
going to be following from now on which
is a rule I used to follow a long time
ago before you know I got too many
responsibilities and that was that
training takes priority in my day and
that is an ironclad rule it doesn't
matter what else is going on I forgot a
deadline if I'm tired even if I'm very
fatigued for my previous workout I don't
actually need to train I'm going to go
to the gym and just do Mobility stuff
this is a daily thing any day I'm
working any day I have a full day of
work I'm going to the gym first and if
that means that I miss a deadline well
then I'm gonna have to work late and try
hard but it might mean that I missed a
deadline it's actually Ben Patrick who
inspired me on this I started it about a
month before the new year and I've been
continuing it into 2023 so far and I
feel the best I've felt in ages it's
fantastic he also said that he trains on
the days that he films so he's filming
fatigued I'm not gonna do that if I'm
filming I'm not going to train that day
but otherwise I train no matter what
I've been feeling great as a result so I
always used to aim to train in the
morning but I'd also allow myself if I
was very busy or something to put it off
and then train in the evening instead
unfortunately this would tend to happen
more more often and then suddenly
psychologically your training isn't
taking priority anymore and what's more
is that often by the evening I'd be
feeling too tired or I'd ran out of time
and it would end up not happening at all
I still managed to train a fair bit but
there's no consistency there and this
was becoming an issue and especially as
to me I view my fitness it's kind of
like the product you know I can't
promote and talk about all these
different types of training without
walking the walk so it's really
important I think to fix this so this is
an ironclad Rule now and there's no
getting around it even if I'm over tired
injured sick I still go to the gym
that's the only rule that I go to the
gym or wherever I'm going to train
whether that's in the woods one day or
whether it's in my office or at home
whatever the case I go as though I'm
doing the workout and that might just
end up being just a few stretches but I
always go there's no excuse because
really there is no excuse not to go if
it's a working day a normal working day
then I train first that is the priority
and this is actually liberating in some
ways because it removes any decision
making I don't have to think oh I'm
really tired or fatigued I'm not going
to be able to train today should I train
shouldn't I now I just know that
whatever the case I'm gonna go and
thereby I can make all my other plans
around that I've made Ironclad rules
like this in the past and it's helped me
in everything for my relationships to my
career so my advice is maybe consider
doing something similar think of the
goal you want to achieve but instead of
setting the goal think about a simple
straightforward rule that you can stick
to that's in your control and just
follow that I'm not the first to give
this advice but it's worked wonders for
me I've also started a new supplement
regimen I'm not going to go into that in
too much detail now because I'm going to
talk about it in an upcoming video but
suffice to say that I think it has
really helped and boosted my performance
and aided my recovery I talked in my
burnout video about the phosphatidylsery
and about the inositol and I do think
that they've have helped there's a
little bit more to it than that as well
in terms of what I'm focusing on
specifically with my training well I'm
going to be focusing on a few things
I've got a few different goals that I'm
working on for one I'm working on my
handstand push-up right now I feel much
more confident in my hands I can balance
a lot more easily and so it is now more
of a strength challenge than a balance
and technique challenge a lot of the
time which is great because it means I
can train more often practice more often
I don't need to be by a wall this has
kind of been like a clicking turning
point I was always able to do handstands
and sometimes I could do a handstand
push-up but it was always very
unreliable it'll take me a few attempts
to kick up and then I couldn't stay up
very long whereas now I at least know
what I need to do I can feel how to
catch myself when I'm under balancing
which was my big issue so I'm going to
be really working on that hands down
push-up over the coming weeks and months
that's going to be a big focus of my
training I also want to re-pick back up
my planche training because I want to
get my straight arm strength better I
was making some progress on that for a
bout of illness and engine series and
now I want to pick it back up where I
left off because I was getting pretty
close to a straddle planche certainly an
advanced tuck planche I can do for a
while so I'm starting to see progress
there I don't want to carry on beyond
that I have some Mobility areas that
still need work I've got good mobility
in some areas I could squat deeply for
days I can do a really nice easy deep
Cossack squat this is all without
warming up however my shoulder Mobility
is still lacking and that is a little
bit of a limiting factor when it comes
to the handstands at the same time I
want to get my pancake stretch a lot
better I think some of this is going to
help prevent the back pain in future and
that of course is another big Focus my
back has been a little bit of a weak
link for me in the past so I want to
make sure I'm really fortifying it and
doing everything I can to make sure that
it gets stronger so those are some
focuses
it can be humbling to discover this and
admit it to yourself especially if
you're a so-called Fitness influencer
and you're supposed to be great at
everything but you know I like everybody
else certainly have areas that need
drastic improvement and it's really
important that we be honest with
ourselves about this even if it's
uncomfortable and focus on those things
and actually if you're starting a new
training program at the start of 2023
what better time to do a kind of
self-mot a diagnostics test to see where
you're at and what you need to work on
because these issues if you ignore them
they get worse and worse they compound
over time and eventually they're going
to make themselves known in the form of
an injury and that's going to be a
setback I'm also going to be focusing a
little bit more on hypertrophy and
bodybuilding style training having a
better physique gives you a little bit
more credibility and it shouldn't
necessarily be that way but it is and so
it's something I think can benefit me in
multiple walks of life in particular I
want to improve my shoulders get some
more cap to delts and this goes hand in
hand with the handstand training
fortunately I also want to improve my
legs a little bit aesthetically I don't
want to get them too big and bulky so
that they slow down my calisthenics
progress you know big heavy legs make it
a bit harder to do things like planche
but I do want to get them you know a
little bit more toned you know so that I
don't look like I just Skip Leg stay
because I don't I want to run faster as
well and I want to jump higher these are
less concrete goals but I'm looking at
some point this year I want to work with
a sprinting a running coach someone who
can help me with my sprinting I've had
some comments on my sprinting form and
I've noticed when watching videos back
that one arm kind of flares out to the
side I don't know what's up with that so
I definitely think I could use some
advice there I am a fast guy naturally
so yeah that's something else that I'm
going to be focusing on so at this point
I'm running faster looking stronger and
I'm also improving my mobility and
gaining some calisthenic skills
so that might sound like a bit of an all
over the place set of goals and it is
but I have been designing a training
program that pretty much allows me to
train in this way it's essentially
adapted from the protein performance
system which you can find in the link in
the description down below by the way
but it's you know modified to suit me
and I have been toning down the number
of repetitions pulling back on the um
strength endurance aspect of things so I
can focus a little bit more on
hypertrophy strength control range of
motion and those things actually now my
training program isn't so much a regular
routine as it is a kind of pool of
exercises which I can pull from as
needed what I've actually done lately is
to enter a bunch of my favorite
exercises into a notion database and
then I'm able to categorize them and
filter them based on different things so
for instance an exercise might be
categorized by the muscles that it
targets what kind of workout it fits
into or that's Push Pull legs or even
cardio importantly though I also
categorize all the exercises based on
where I need to be to train them so
although I can use the exercise at home
whether it needs specific equipment I
can only get it game but that's
something I can do outdoors with just
the kind of environment so that I can
use filters in order to show all the
exercises that I can do in a given
location that's going to Target the
things I want to Target and get the
results I want to get then I can select
my favorite ones and I can easily look
and see which muscles are being targeted
what the traits being worked are and I
can swap different ones out or choose
which ones I want to do that day this is
the system I'll be linking to in the
description you can check that out for
yourself if you're interested keep in
mind though that this is designed to be
flexible and it's also written for me
not for you guys there's no sets and
Reps a lot of them are going to sound
odd or weirdly specific if you want a
structured routine with sets and Reps
and things that's based along the same
principles then of course check out the
protein performance system which I'll
put a link to in the description down
below there's a sale on right now for
January so yeah good time to check it
out if you're interested
in terms of the channel going forwards
and the brand there's a few things that
I am looking to do a bit differently the
first is kind of like the behind the
scenes stuff in terms of management I
want to take a slightly more hands-off
approach and don't worry I don't mean
I'm not going to be presenting I don't
mean I'm not going to be editing and
doing all those things I want to do a
little bit less emailing I don't really
enjoy that side of things I like to just
get down and write and I really want to
put more emphasis on the blog itself and
write more blog posts because I am a
heart a writer I love deep dives into
subjects that wouldn't necessarily
perform well on YouTube so I want to do
more of that and if I'm also going to be
placing more emphasis on my training and
doing that at the start of my days then
I'm gonna have less time of course to be
doing admin and stuff which like I say
I'm not good at and don't want to do
anyways there's so many emails so many
opportunities they're just sitting in my
inbox and people are getting frustrated
with me because I just don't have time
to film all this stuff so I'm hopefully
going to be working with an admin
assistant someone who can do some of
that stuff with me I'm going to be
looking into ways to streamline this
process and even like Outsourcing things
like I'm doing shorts and I'm hoping to
Outsource the editing things like that
just there's a little bit less on my
plate there I can focus more on the
things that I hope bring real value and
I actually enjoy doing and be a little
bit less stressed and exhausted and like
I say the channel has been taking a
little bit of a dive in terms of
viewership and view count so I need to
experiment with different types of
content on the site and see what's going
to be more successful it's really hard
balancing act because you don't want to
sell out obviously and just do all the
stuff that you think YouTube wants you
to do but at the same time you do need
the views and especially because you
know it's my income and it's how I
support my family and if I want to do
things like Outsourcing some of those
things then I need more income in order
to be able to support that so yeah one
of the big lessons for me then is really
managing my recovery and as I've always
talked about on this channel not just
thinking about your exercise and your
training in isolation you have to think
about the bigger picture and your health
overall if you're not sleeping then you
need to train less and if you have a
very physically demanding job then you
need to train less or you need to find
ways to fit that training in around that
demanding job and if that demanding job
is already taken care of some aspects of
your strength and performance then your
goal is to bring up the rest of your
physique and the rest of your
performance to match if you think about
your training and your lifestyle not as
separate things but as part of one
bigger picture then you can get far
better results in the end and that's why
it's a really useful strategy to not
just think about specific goals I'm
going to do this and I'm gonna eat this
and I'm gonna you know exercise like
this think in terms of how you're going
to redesign your entire routine and your
entire lifestyle to facilitate the goals
that you want and for me that often
means implementing rules think about all
the different aspects that might be
filtering in on that whether it's your
mental health whether it's your diet
whether it's your sleep and Recovery
whether it's your career whatever it is
it does have some impact on every other
aspect of your life
anyways guys I hope you found this
useful and interesting in some way if
nothing else it shows you a kind of road
map what I'm hoping to achieve then you
guys can follow along with me and watch
my training and see if I'm actually
achieving and following through on those
goals hopefully it gives me a little bit
of accountability I'd love to know your
goals and Ambitions for 2023 breathing
training in business that kind of stuff
let me know in the comments down below
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and I'll see you
next time
bye for now